[Música]
o som é de introdução é o xandros porque
uma das minhas idéias presta presta anos
presta a partilha de experiências é
tornar isso mais informal possível
nós vimos tanto eu como o luis está aqui
na na apresentando aqui no edifício nós
nós vimos uma semana num evento em um
esgoto aqui focado o exame e trazemos
também alguma inspiração porque aumentar
este ano e perceber do que na
informalidade que a gente ganhe a
partilha é acontecem tantos livros que
aproveitar a sua experiência e um
exemplo magnífico por exemplo josé fala
em como eu terem terem partir disso
porque o próprio exemplo minha ver uma
chance de chuva já que entra e ia falar
com o alto responsável da amazônia só
possuía no final e eu vou partilhar
comigo a experiência avião e vamos
mostrar um beijo tanto e sei que é
fantástico um evento como este para
iniciar efetivamente falar a cerveja não
saibam ganhar é é é um caso complicado
ainda mais relevante em portugal
agora já não tanto mas há uns anos é um
líquido amarelo sem gás que nós vivemos
numa praia para buscarmos podemos contar
com seu futebol
quando temos um futebol música curtir
uma onça portanto é difícil trabalhar
cerveja em portugal e é difícil falar
sobre cerveja é no sábado de manhã
qualquer forma em 2010 percebemos que
não
vamos tentar perceber como é que estou
se ana ela vai entrar não está a
funcionar
ok civil em 2010 que é é após algumas
viagens após gastarem menos dinheiro em
uma semana na bélgica uma semana mãe e e
dormir nené mala uma ford transit
estamos em implementar um regime essas
velhas só por isso tivemos que a cerveja
é muito mais do que fui que o amor é uma
cerveja pode ser um conceito pode ser um
negócio e no valor total em portugal em
temos agora uma chance de sindh e agora
se lê jornais e tudo todo o contexto
alto valor e por último valor se ela
está muito na moda em 2010
não existe nada em que vivemos que temos
já tem negócios conceito que era
trabalhar umas cervejas diferentes com
altos padrões de qualidade com uma
perspectiva diferenciadora conquista
sabor de intensidade do seu hoje é como
boa imagem com martin uma perspectiva
educacional do negócio que associada à
marca
precisamos estar lá e precisamos
desenvolver uma estratégia para
licenciar uma pequena unidade de
produção uma fábrica sem existir
legislação para isso tanto
sabemos que vamos ter uma grande batalha
desenvolvimento de uma estratégia porque
queríamos ter uma marca local marginal e
que partes a partir de uma vila de uma
cidade e precisamos ter parceiros na
região
foi isso que fizeram estamos instalados
em vila verde e foi conga municipal vila
verde iniciaram já a aventura que se
cruza com o início da aventura da silva
de andrade em portugal devemos tomar um
banho que queremos associar ao nosso
produto estas infâncias convidada uma
experiência para o consumidor e
desenhamos é o nosso primeiro grupo
envolver o tamanho neste momento está aí
já está em atividade há um ano atrás não
traria quando as pessoas pudessem
conhecer e perceber porque é que a
cerveja tem aquelas qualidades porque eu
tenho aquela intensidade pudessem
visitar a fábrica pudesse dizer que
cerca uma hora é normal acontecer em
2030 ano em marketing e eles passaram em
uma tarde conosco este trabalho seria
possível um processo
os praianos é uma experiência
absolutamente incrível e que os
portugueses ainda estão a descobrir e
então o nosso produto não é só esse
líquido amarelo essa cerveja com mais
intensidade o nosso produto é essa
experiência associada a cerveja foi
necessário é basicamente ficou 12 metros
brutal começou com como ideia lavo nós
cobramos a este negócio passou por por
um estudo o mercado passou por uma
unidade piloto que nós próprios não
desenhamos não só mas construímos ok e
que nós possamos vender pra essas nossas
missões mais limitadas que servimos nas
principais lojas especializadas em
portugal mas também não traria para
assaltar um banco por uma prova de
conceito que fizemos com pessoas aqui da
região da área experimental das nossas
ruas passou plan o encerramento de uma
unidade criada legislação não fomos nós
que criamos que ajudamos a criar digamos
assim e passar também por captação de
algum investimento e desenhar nosso
próprio layout fábrica
nós fizemos em uma viagem no sentido de
investir três vezes - sendo nós a
desenhar nosso layout forma que neste
momento é um produto da empresa e que é
este
duas das marcas portuguesas já contam
com esse nosso serviço em do ponto de
vista da implementação das suas falas
nós somos um caminho mais do que fazer
uma cirurgia em casa e colocar um rótulo
e avançavam mercado tanto algum filme
temos um passado ligado à universidade e
esta esta perspectiva de desenvolvimento
de explorar ao máximo a inovação é um
direito absoluto
somos temos a nossa carreira ligada às
indústrias dos das fermentações na minha
área mas ligada à parte de
biocombustíveis inclusive a terminar o
doutoramento é não ser uma tecnologia
para o processo de alta produtividade
2009 coisas que em portugal têm pouco
interesse mas quem pensa que mostraram
menos no brasil é altamente
interessantes da empresa é fermento
situa-se ao i na interface entre a
universidade e indústria e nesta
perspectiva vai desenvolvendo para além
da cerveja é o principal produto
vai jogar será uma experiência se a
cerveja inúmeros projetos de
desenvolvimento têm inscrição e
regulamento
um dos projetos que têm tido em que já
resultou num produto da empresa é
estudar tecnologias para as obras é a
aceleração do envelhecimento e no
estágio da silvana de outras vindas em
barricas de carvalho sintonizado do que
outras
o objetivo aqui é mesmo a cantar com seu
vigor e intensidade de sabor um pouco no
vinho do porto traz frio passa hoje
temos uma cerveja que tem
características muito mais especiais e
que está neste momento a ser usada como
um projeto de internacionalização da
marca letra no sentido de explorar o
destino cervejas lá fora com uma forte
ligação à nossa indústria do vinho
estamos também em vila verde é trabalhar
ao que é muito querido pra vila que é
estudar novas variedades do do grupo
vila verde uma maior contenção e de
estação de tratamento ou quatro anos
atrás
neste momento estamos com um projeto
ainda é uma fase piloto de voltar a
trazer o grupo vila verde isto começa a
tornar se ia criar aqui um cluster a
volta da cerveja não temos um produto a
ser produzido com uma fala que é com um
crescimento de 25 30% ao ano
então é uma experiência da cerveja com o
primeiro grupo da marca como a plantação
no cu nós como marca temos a capacidade
de avançar disse que em breve a primeira
plantação de uma nova variedade tem
interesse ao de custo ou quatro vezes
mais suprirá a variedade plantada há 30
anos nós importamos diretamente os
resumos da soja estamos a estudá los no
sentido da possibilidade de se envolver
em transformar num gesto pouco pra
exportar para os países da europa
temos gente consegue atrair aqui é que é
fundamental quer a parte da visita era
parte da experiência associada outro
cruzamento da economia
veja em várias cervejas um patamar mais
alto significa como foi feito com o
vinho há 20 30 anos atrás eram bem cada
vez mais harmonizado como foi com com a
nossa gastronomia extra
como podem ver na imagem fazemos em uma
das visitas na perspectiva educacional
deixar claro às pessoas que as chuvas
regionais podem acompanhar uma refeição
e podem podem atingir um valor
acrescentado
comparativamente ao fim como falar e
desenvolvemos um layout fábrica aqui
neste momento situa se entre os 12 a 14
mil milhões por mês é maior unidade em
portugal está dotada de comissões para o
chefe
isso para nós é a empresa do ponto de
vista de um metro de altura foi muito
importante
temos um conjunto diferente neste
momento temos nossas google acho que são
as letras está um bom marco inicial do
produto a perspectiva de francisco silva
já diferentes letras no sentido as
pessoas iam experimentando e conseguirem
perceber a diferença entre os produtos
que no chão e entrou ao que é marca de
cervejas maturada em berlim que as
utilizadas vinho do porto diz que téo
uma parceria com a quinta do portal em
um jogo orgulho ea esta perspectiva é a
nível mundial de cada vez mais se
existirem são limitadas de coisas
completamente diferentes que as pessoas
provam e ficam completamente loucas
poucos são os robôs completamente
estranhos mas muito bons eo burnley são
edições limitadas nós fazemos para o
nosso vale para as lojas mais utilizados
em portugal não sei se vocês ainda a
imagem pessoal neste momento existem já
algumas dessas duas partes lojas
opcional o setor de micro setor thakshin
cada vez mais existem investimentos
brutais que estão a iniciar
inclusive eu não letal banho sábado 17
portanto é um setor que está a ser a
marca tem essa perspectiva positiva
pronta será como a realização de
inúmeros eventos solidários por exemplo
principalmente em envolver nós chamamos
de vila verde temos orgulho de ser
brasileiro e trabalhamos com com as
pessoas do governo
isso para nós é fundamental lançamos
este ano oitavas em francês que o
festival afiada como em todo o mundo
fizemos bonito muito escura um gesto do
ponto de vista turístico trouxeram cerca
de 60 pessoas no futebol há muito por
não estar 13 dirigentes do governo e
isso é uma experiência que as pessoas
hoje em dia pagam porque é uma
experiência única
participamos disso um dos
coorganizadores aliás alguns festivais
trabalhar em igual nível entre a nível
nacional e estamos com um projeto em
transmissão da marca a participar em
inúmeros festivais cerveja
especializados a nível europeu
portanto é que temos queria deixar é
importante haver uma idéia é importante
trabalhar saber saber fazer
é uma perspectiva muito difícil mas é
preciso ter mão de obra
construímos uma história ao criar uma
marca e hoje em dia deixamos no fundo a
porta aberta para o futuro e japão os
mesmos acerto com um cão é um
investimento em um novo processo não
posso deixar novidades mas fiquem à
espera de uma nova coisa aí está que
está no chelsea obrigado pela vossa
atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]